So one last point I'd like to show you about domains.
Is browsers generally all have a Preferences page. And here I
am in Chrome's preferences. If I go to Under the Hood,
and I click on Content Settings, I can actually choose some relevant
options. Basically for Cookies, we can Allow all data to be
set. And this basically says, you know, allow all, all cookies to
be set. Now the next option basically says, Only set cookies
that exist in this current session. So when I close my browser,
all those cookies will disappear. You know, we can block
sites from setting, setting any cookies. Or we could block cookies
or, or websites from setting, setting third party cookies. So
that means if reddit.com makes a request to google.com, we won't
accept any google.com cookies. Because our browser says reddit. Even
though we might make requests you know, for images or, or
other things from other domains. And you know, another option,
Clear cookies. So you know, this is kind of well trodden
ground to set you know, which, which domains are allowed to
set what cookies. And generally I usually check this, this box. It
prevents websites from linking to third party data. And then having them
you know, fill your browser with ad tracking stuff. So anyway, I
just thought you should be aware that these are, now you have
more information of how cookie domains work. And what's allowed to set
what. And you can even restrict it even further, or the user
can. So you want to be sure that you know, you're not operating
under the assumption that your cookies may
always be allowed, and may always be there.